hot breath jonathan hernandez
what are two things you would do
differently
in your comedy career and what's one
thing you wish you
knew you knew you'd know
um sorry that was my liberal arts degree
coming out well what is this here
what anyway um
so what are two things you would do
differently in your comedy career and
what's one thing you wish you knew
before starting your career
in a yes or no answer no
jeez things i've done differently i
guess a simple
ques answer is just when i i
was a new face of montreal um out of
chicago
and it was a six minute set and you like
rehearsed it and it was
that's what got me in and and i really
stuck to it and i was scared about
sticking to the time and
i'm very much like type a rule follower
very organized comic
and when i got there it was mostly new
york and la comics
and they're all very nice and stuff but
they were just sort of like
yeah i might go a little over i'm gonna
do a new bit i'm gonna do this
very relaxed and i was like i it's not
that i had this i wasn't the comic that
like necessarily stuck to it
uh annotated or um transcription or
something
but it was something i worked on like it
was it was meticulous
and i just was terrified of going over
and
you know sticking to it and that makes
you
more one-dimensional you know so
i if i could do it over i would say like
listen don't blow the light by 10
minutes but have
have fun i mean have fun is such a it's
really so i'm sick of hearing it
it's it's just like what do you mean
have fun
that's so stupid it's just like be in
the moment
and not worry as much so yes have fun
but
i'm that's bad advice ah so that's what
i would do differently
and hmm
i mean you can't change these things but
the way i put out my albums
is insane and some of it's not even done
i just like
it it's more like
know feeling like you're more in charge
of your career i think there's balance
with that there's comics that come out
like
right away i'm a comic here's my card
and you know
they know and they know what what
they're doing and i was sort of like
somebody
what will you do your album with us we
really love it and i'm like sure
you know it's like kind of
i would be less accepting i would be
more more questioning
of the things and intentions and
um yeah the way i put out my albums
like i said some of those jokes were
jokes i just told for a brief period of
time
and then later i finished them and put
them in a special so in some ways i kind
of like that i did that
or you listen to it on the album and
it's like oh that's funny and then later
you see it done in a special that's kind
of fun
but yeah
and then one thing i wish i knew
[Music]
hmm
it's hard to say
i don't know that's one thing i wish i
knew
i think like i think you said it with
like just
being more mindful of some of the
choices and the people you trusted
yeah i think things like that that when
you're young
and just am like gung-ho here we go
you're just thinking about oh what's
going to give me the heat
or whatnot as opposed to well what do i
want what are my
what do i want to get out of my own
comedy career and not listen to what
other people think my career should be
yeah i think it's you know stand-up's
always something where there are no
rules and there's no boss and there's no
nothing yet
everyone pretty much does the same thing
they get up and they just talk into the
microphone people hold it differently
and
touch it differently and stand
differently but we're all doing the same
thing
so it's odd how individualistic it can
be and yet
people really adhere to the boundaries
so
yeah i think i would just be more
discerning and
i'm thankful for the people i've been
worked with because you know your words
are a magnet
so don't say stuff that you don't want
those people coming to you your words
are a magnet
that is gold right there
yeah you you know you'll reap what you
what you say
or so i'm gonna put that on a magnet
and sell it as merch your
all right so let's be careful